[Applaudissements]
célébrons maintenant une profession peu
évoquée ici au César celle des
exploitants de cinéma ils reçoivent le
public dans leur salle et font tout pour
que les séances soient des moments
mémorables
découvrons 24 heures de la vie
d'exploitant de cinéma à travers Gwendal
et Perrine moucher
chez deux passionnés de cinéma
moins 2 minutes ma Perrine
Gwendal et Perrine boucher dirige la
salle Le Trianon dans le Finistère
comment s'organise leur journée entre
gestion des salles mais surtout cette
fameuse baisse de fréquentation dont on
parle beaucoup pour rajouter de l'eau
parce que il y a encore un peu compact
[Musique]
une place ticket on est arrivé ici il y
a 27 ans pile 9 mois avant la naissance
de notre petite dernière c'est là qu'on
l'a conçu sur ces deux sièges là voilà
de 2 avril 96 deuxième semaine
d'exploitation de Toy Story 1 peut dire
qu'on a bien tordu taper mon Gwendal
on fait ça devant les Marvel sa gueule
tellement à l'écran on est tranquille et
gentil une fois ça c'est marrant on
s'est gouré de salle on a fait ça devant
des hommes et des dieux
je commence ma petite affaire
tout à coup je me dis Perrine il y a un
truc c'est pas comme d'habitude bah oui
vous avez peut-être vu le film c'est des
moines qui prient qui qui peuvent leur
souple alors là ils sont des light les
gens c'est pas dans le film ils sont pas
cons hein on est sorti on respecte
client
ça va pas
une année qui finit mieux qu'elle n'a
démarré grâce au cinéma français qui
reprend des couleurs ce qui est
exceptionnel là récemment c'est novembre
moi j'ai ma petite phrase au guichet
quand ces clients me demandaient je
disais novembre alors c'est une comédie
on rit mais pas que et puis Simone moi
je me suis pris en pleine poire comme
tout le monde les gens étaient fous
Simone là il s'évanouissait dans le haut
Simone Veil c'est c'est la bière quoi
en juif
pour booster la fréquentation dans leur
salle Gwendal et Perrine sont prêtes à
tout y compris à aller chercher les
clients chez eux à domicile
je suis désolé j'ai oublié que j'ai du
monde ce soir et j'ai pas fait mon
ménage je vais devoir sauter la séance
vitre aspirateur vaisselle débouchage de
commodité les mouches n'hésitent pas à
mouiller le maillot pour que les clients
reviennent en salle vous êtes prêtes
madame on vous emmène mais avec les
Mouchets
il y a des limites à ne pas dépasser
installez-vous dans la voiture on arrive
d'accord à tout de suite
[Musique]
merde
avec la grande tradition des
avant-projections des années 50 nos deux
saltimbanques n'hésitent pas à payer de
nouveau de leur personne les clients ont
définitivement les yeux pleins d'étoiles
cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]